[Music]
welcome to this lecture on the
fundamentals of the stock market today
we're talking about understanding the
risks and potential returns of investing
the stock market suppose you just turned
67 at the end of 2012 and it just
retired you would save for retirement
starting at the age of 40 until you
retired on your 67th birthday having
invested all of your contributions in
the stock market and reinvested all the
dividends how well would you have done
if you began this saving with your first
contributions to your retirement account
in 1986 at the end of your first year of
work under the retirement plan assuming
starting income of $50,000 an inflation
rate of 2% per year a real salary growth
rate of 1% and the contribution each
year of 10% of your income you would
have ended up with five hundred and
ninety two thousand dollars in your
account at the end of 2012 not bad for
having not started to save until age 40
what if instead you'd been a few years
older and it started this with your
first contribution again at age 40 in
1983
instead of 1986 your 67th birthday would
have occurred the trough of the stock
market in February 2009 if you retired
at that point you would have ended up
with around four hundred and twenty nine
thousand dollars or around 28% less than
if you had started three years later now
with the benefit of hindsight it is
clear that people who hung in there with
the stock market in February 2009 saw
their balances recover but at the time
there was great concern about the stock
market when you really get into the
situation of having just seen a little
less than half your retirement wealth
evaporate in the span of a year it's
difficult to know what to do if there
really is mean reversion in the stock
market meaning that extreme increases
and extreme decreases will level out
over time then once you just hang in
there through the downturns and sell off
your position slowly during big booms
but this is a very difficult path to
force yourself to follow specifically
when everyone is making money in the
stock market it's hard to force yourself
to sell out of it and when everyone is
losing money it's hard to stick with it
or buy more stocks
and importantly we don't really know if
the stock market really mean reverts we
don't know that in all cases after the
market Falls that it will rebound we
only have one history of the stock
market in the u.s. if we look around the
globe we can find examples of countries
whose stock markets never recovered or
took a very very long time to recover
here for example is a graph of the
Japanese stock market the Nikkei 225 it
got almost 240 thousand points in 1989
it then fell to below 10,000 points
that's a 75% decline by April 2013 it's
recovered to around 13,000 but this is
very far from the high of almost 40,000
at the end of 1989 in this lecture we'll
make some progress towards understanding
the stock market many individuals invest
in stocks deciding that they like the
risk return trade-off that they perceive
in the stock market for example consider
401k plans the leading retirement saving
vehicle for private sector workers in
the US with over three trillion dollars
of assets in them as of today at least
44 percent of 401k assets owned by
participants in their 20s is invested in
stocks and 41 percent of the assets for
participants in their 60s is invested in
stocks those figures don't even include
other types of retirement account
investments such as target date funds
and balanced funds which also include
some equities and then there are the
large pension funds that manage
trillions of dollars of money to provide
pensions to government employees and
also the older employees of firms and
more traditional industries these
pension funds have also chosen to invest
in the stock market at the end of 2012
state and local governments had around 3
trillion dollars in us-based pension
funds as well with around 1.8 trillion
dollars in corporate stocks the stock
market consists of the traded equity
stakes in all publicly traded companies
in this lecture I won't be talking too
much about individual stocks but more
about the stock market as a whole one of
the major principles that you learn if
you study individual stocks is that
there are substantial benefits to
diversification diversification is the
combination of the stocks of many
different companies into a portfolio
what we are covering in this lecture is
how financial economists generally think
about
in the stock market Financial Economics
views the stock market as if use any
other asset there are many different
states of the world whether the economy
is good or bad whether natural resources
are cheaper expensive whether inflation
is high or low and an asset is
characterized by its performance in each
of those different states of the world
historically stocks have had a higher
return than risk free assets but that
higher return is not guaranteed and the
lack of the guarantee the fact that the
stock market can generate much lower
returns in the risk-free asset in some
states of the world is what makes it
possible the stock market can
potentially deliver higher returns than
the risk-free rate in other states
[Music]